todo quedó listo para que el presidente
de martín vizcarra front este viernes un
proceso de destitución que impulsó el su
contra el congreso de perú la decisión
del tribunal constitucional habilita al
parlamento peruano a continuar con el
proceso de vacancia presidencial la
máxima corte de este país considera que
no hay urgencia para suspender la
vacancia porque al criterio de los
magistrados no es un tema que sea
eminentemente irreparable así las cosas
se espera que el mandatario se presente
este viernes a las 10 de la mañana en el
parlamento o lo represente su abogado
los legisladores necesitan 87 votos para
declarar la vacancia presidencial por
incapacidad moral pero existe
incertidumbre porque los diputados no
cuentan con los votos suficientes
algunos grupos políticos cambiaron su
posición luego de que el jefe del
parlamento manuel merino y otros
legisladores fueron expuestos de
conspirar y llamar a altos mandos
militares antes de que el pleno del
congreso aprobara la moción que autoriza
el impeachment por eso representantes de
algunos partidos anunciaron que no
apoyarán la vacancia presidencial con
escasos aliados martín vizcarra realista
su estrategia para enfrentar a un
parlamento opositor el mandatario tiene
el desafío de defender su cargo y
conservar
de los peruanos